mom I need to talk to you what is it
sweetie
what's wrong I wanted to tell you this
for a long time but I was scared very
scared of how you'd react I can't keep
lying to you anymore I'm straight
[Music]
we are gonna get you late tonight I know
this girl and she would be perfect for
you I'm straight I knew it my weekend
was great I went up to Napa with my
fiance
that sounds beautiful you married at all
I don't know oh you have a boyfriend or
no actually I'm uh I'm straight Oh
oh cool my ex-boyfriend said we should
take a trip
oh you're straight oh I had no idea it
was just like touchdown after touchdown
Oh God you guys here Wow
okay yeah we get it you're straight yeah
breeder shut up maybe you're just
confused I mean it's probably just a
phase right I just don't want you to go
to hell because you chose to be straight
[Music]
I'm straight I was born straight I can't
change who I am
there's nothing wrong with me and I
accept that
hey do you mind if I no not at all thank
you are you are you here with a
girlfriend
no I don't have a girlfriend
I don't swing that way really I'm sorry
I it's just really nice to finally meet
another person like you yeah hi I'm Nick
Lauren hey hey
[Music]